bonsoir dans une maison merci d'être
avec nous alors que peut-on retenir de
cette rencontre entre le président russe
vladimir poutine et son homologue
biélorusse alexandre loukachenko
le premier point c'est que l'adf que
monsieur le coaching qu a voulu
ostensiblement se placer sous la
protection de la lumière poutine et qui
lui a dit et répété qu'il était le
dernier rempart pour protéger la russie
alors de l'avenir poutine a semble-t-il
répondu qu'il usait toute confiance
puisqu'il était un homme politique
expérimenté au pouvoir depuis 1994
c'est-à-dire depuis 26 ans bien plus
longtemps que vladimir poutine lui-même
excusé toute confiance pour résoudre ce
problème qui est un problème interne à
la biélorussie donc avec l'idée que
c'est à la biélorussie de le résoudre
y compris par le référendum puisque
monsieur k cecco a évoqué cette
hypothèse à minsk il y a quelques jours
en l'assortissant d'ailleurs de
conditions évidemment on peut
s'interroger sur la crédibilité de
monsieur loukachenko crème là puisqu'au
cours des dernières années il a beaucoup
louvoyé il a accepté en 2017 après le 20
millions d'euros pour la biélorussie au
titre de la coopération avec les pays
d'europe centrale que proposait
bruxelles
il a aussi refusé avec une grande
constance de mettre en vigueur le traité
qui prévoyait une sorte de fusion entre
la russie et la biélorussie qui
prévoyait d'établir une confédération
avec une fusion d'un certain nombre de
secteurs et en décembre encore lors
d'une rencontre avec le président
biélorusse monsieur poutine a dit mais
il n'ya même pas 90% de du contenu de ce
traité qu'ils soient mises en oeuvre par
la biélorussie et je me demande bien
pourquoi
alors quelle est la situation économique
du bélarus pour ne pas qu'on comprenne
le contexte le bélarus état est un petit
état d'environ 10 millions d'habitants
qui pourraient avoir une économie
beaucoup plus dynamique qu'elle ne l'est
aujourd'hui
en effet il y à des ingénieurs très
compétents des gens très compétents dans
le domaine du numérique et des gens très
dynamiques qui sont en état de créer des
entreprises
seulement voilà le problème c'est que
monsieur le cachet connais pas un
réformateur
il a reçu l'économie de la biélorussie
en héritage en 2000 en 1994 et que à
l'époque c'était une économie néo
soviétique et dont le fond pas grand
chose a changé depuis cette époque
c'est-à-dire depuis 26 ans le secteur
public représente 70% de l'économie ça
d'ailleurs des avantages parce que il ya
peu de chômage
et puis ça permet à monsieur le cas de
cheikh lô qui a transformé il ya deux
ans tous les contrats à durée
indéterminée en contrat à durée
déterminée d'exercer une pression sur
les gens qui travaillent dans ces
entreprises publiques et lorsqu'ils sont
mécontents comme ça s'est produit ces
dernières semaines est bien de les
menacer de sanctions ou de licenciement
par ailleurs l'économie biélorusse est
très dépendante de la russie
80% de son énergie vient de la russie et
pour son commerce extérieur elle dépend
à 60% de la russie donc tout ça montre
que en un quart de siècle dans le fond
c'est un peu un échec de la gestion
économique de monsieur loukachenko et
peut-être que ceux ci d'ailleurs suffi à
le discréditer
alors la réforme constitutionnelle
évoqué est promise par alexandre
loukachenko pour sortir de la crise
ailleurs le kremlin a confirmé cette
promesse du président biélorusse ce
qu'elle est plus que nous
c'est selon lui il peut changer les
choses alors la meilleure poutine a
raison il a pris le catch nko'o mots
loukachenko a prononcé le mot référendum
devant les ouvriers de l usine de
tracteurs à minsk et il a dit mais je
peut réformer la constitution
avoir une nouvelle répartition des
pouvoirs faire un référendum et ensuite
de nouvelles élections
et puis après il a eu l'air de se
rétracter un petit peu ayant un petit
peu peur de sa propre audace mais il l'a
dit et vladimir poutine le prend au mot
ce qui signifie que ils pensent que en
effet il ya lieu de réformer la
constitution qui est le russe alors
maintenant comment faire évidemment qui
mettre autour de la table pour préparer
un nouveau texte de constitution
est ce que monsieur loukachenko
acceptera de faire venir des
représentants de l'opposition politique
des gens qui manifestent dans la rue
depuis son élection
des gens qui sont en exil ou des gens
qui sont en prison pour discuter du
nouveau projet de constitution s'il le
rédige tout seul évidemment ça ne
résoudra pas le problème politique alors
il ya les experts dans beaucoup de pays
des experts russes des experts dans les
pays de l'union européenne des experts
dans les organisations internationales
qui peuvent l'aider à rédiger cette
constitution alors quelles peuvent être
les acteurs pour sortir de la crise
alors bien sûr la russie est un acteur
majeur et la russie a intérêt à ce que
ce qui se passe en biélorussie se calme
donc pour le moment
elle demande à monsieur lukaku de faire
le nécessaire
elle lui fait confiance compte tenu de
son expérience politique encore une fois
mais il n'est pas certain que si le
désordre continuer si monsieur koceku
s'avérait impossible de résoudre la
crise que moscou reste les bras ballants
devant cette situation
alors il ya plusieurs solutions est en
effet moscou pas cherché à intervenir
par la voie juridique ou par d'autres
moyens
évidemment
la russie et la biélorussie font partie
comme ça et élire leur conférence de
presse de l'organisation du traité de
sécurité de coopération qui regroupe
aussi quatre autres pays d'asie centrale
et cette organisation qui date de 2002 a
pour objet de veiller à la sécurité les
uns et les autres
par conséquent on voit bien que monsieur
loukachenko a envie de faire appel à
cette organisation du traité de sécurité
de coopération qui réunit six pays de
l'ancienne union soviétique
on pourrait aussi penser à
l'organisation de sécurité de
coopération européenne dont la russie et
la biélorussie font également partie
comme pratiquement tous les pays
d'europe est loin c'est d'ailleurs
proposé ses bons offices
mais monsieur le catch échos dont
l'objectif principal semble être de
garder le pouvoir contre vents et marées
n'a pas envie de voir ces acteurs
extérieurs intervenir alors peut-être
une dernière remarque après tout la
biélorussie n'est le seul pays européen
qui ne soit pas membre du conseil de
l'europe
c'est un peu une bizarrerie mais la
biélorussie avait posé sa candidature en
1993 et puis monsieur loukachenko est
arrivé au pouvoir en 1994 il n'a plus
montré aucun intérêt pour cette
organisation dont la russie fait partie
et dans tous les pays d'europe
à l'est comme à l'ouest font partie donc
peut-être qu'un jour il aura envie de
rejoindre le conseil de l'europe
merci beaucoup au club blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales de
nous avoir apporté votre analyse